uh cowbank tao
um okay i see you here you wanna go
ahead and project your screen
yes
okay great i see your slides right so
it's my pleasure to
introduce uh professor chao wang at the
university of southern california
um carl is an associate professor at usc
and uh he has worked extensively on many
topics
in software engineering formal methods
and related areas
he has published two books and and
many papers and many of them have been
recognized with
paper award when he's received the early
career award for the nsf from
our and a distinguished presentation
about it
tau has been doing some very exciting
work on synthesis and its applications
and eager to hear about yesterday
can you hear me now yes we can hear you
okay uh first uh thanks for the
invitation
and uh i'm happy to talk about our work
on
sciton analysis first i want to
acknowledge my collaborators over the
years especially beijing
who is currently a phd student at usc
and she is the driving force
behind this work
today i'm going to first uh briefly
explaining uh
uh briefly explain what side channel
analysis is and then i'll talk about a
specific type called powerset channel
and then after that i will talk about a
few key ideas behind our method
and finally i'll show the evaluation
results
i think most people heard about side
channel in 2018 after
the meltdown inspector attacks were
revealed
so these are the attacks that affected
many uh
microprocessors in those personal
computers
and also data centers
and the main thing behind this is a
cache timing set channel
it's due to a higher level optimization
called the speculative execution
but this is only one example of many
possible side channels there
are more and if you look at here
besides timing there can be sound heat
dm emission
power and even injected thoughts they
all can be used
as a side channels so today's talk i'm
going to be focusing on one type called
power side channel
but in this context a static analyzer
is a software tool that for a given
program and a leakage model try to
decide whether it has a such channel
leaks
here the leaks are really statistical
dependencies between
the secret data and the uh what you can
observe from the side channel
and like any static analyzer when you
try to design one
and you place the trade-off among
soundness
completeness and termination or
practically fast
so in this context we choose soundness
and termination
and this is reasonable for security
applications for example
if you are not sure whether a software
code
a piece of software code is is
vulnerable or not
you don't want to say that it's not
vulnerable and then the next question is
how do you design
such a analyzer so there are two options
you can manually craft it
or you can use data driven synthesis
uh they're disadvantage of manually
crafting that analyzer it's
labor-intensive error chrome and it can
be
sub-optimal and also once you design the
analyzer it's
harder to adapt to the changing
characteristics of the target program
but if you use
data driven synthesis you can avoid all
these problems
so next i will use a few examples to
explain
the nature of the power section
so i want to start with the classic
example which is the a smart card
running like encryption algorithm so
here you can see the
bit streams coming in these are the
plaintext
and then the bitstream's going out
there's a cipher text
there is also a chief specific crypto
key here
and you want to keep it secret because
otherwise encryption is not going to be
very useful
but if you are able to observe the
fluctuations of the power consumption
where you're running the
encryption algorithm then it might be
fairly easy
for you to deduce some sensitive uh
information about the key
and that's called side channel attack so
there are well known techniques for
doing that
for power side channel there is this
differential power analysis
and and like here if you put a current
sensor
between the power supply and the
computing device
so this is the embedded computing
hardware running some cryptographic
software
then you can measure the uh power
consumption over time and using the
oscilloscope
and then you can collect many of them
and then put it in a
pc and then you try to do some kind of
statistic analysis
and if if if the secret data are not
protected even by
countermeasures this might be fairly
easy right you can
directly see the sensitive data from
from this kind of a power measurement
trace
where were the for fingerprints so
that's why
counter measures are widely used in this
context and for power set channel
the most popular one is called masking
and you're using some random bit strings
to uh to try to break the statistical
dependencies between
the secret data and what you can observe
from the power side channel
so in this slides i want to use a um
a few a few few examples to try to
illustrate at a high level what this
masking is doing
so let's assume that you have a leaky
computation
there's a boolean function f x and you
don't want
the sensitive input x to be lift through
this yellow box
what you can do is to take a random bit
try to use xor to randomize the input
before you fit it into
this leaky computation so whatever that
is going to be linked through this
yellow box
is randomized so if someone has to
aggregate it over time they will get
white noise
but then you also want to recover the c
right
so then you take the same bit string you
fit into the same function f
you get fr and then you xor this with
the output you would recover this
this is very nice but it only works if f
is a linear function uh linear in terms
of the xor operator
but you know real world cryptographic
software
they all have nonlinear components so
you really cannot do that
in any straightforward fashion so you
would have to ask a domain expert
to try to rewrite this entire program to
bake
the countermeasure in from the ground up
but even after that you have no idea if
the software code is implemented
correctly so
so there is verification needed here
so here i'm i'm trying to use this this
small example to illustrate
what uh the side channel is right it's
the statistical dependencies between the
secret bit and what you can observe
through the sound check
so here the chi function has one of the
input
the secret bit i want and if you can
observe something related to the value
of n1
the question is can you infer something
from n1 about to the value of i1 so for
that we can build a truth table
and here in this truth table i1 is one
of the input columns and one is one of
the output columns
and you notice if i1 has value zero
out of the four rows one of them
and one has logic one but if
i1 is uh one then
three out of four cases and one is one
so if we know that you know in a cmos
device in a circuit
the logical one consume a little bit
static
current than logic zero
then by observing the output you might
be able to infer something about
the input of the secret bit so that's
a side channel now in order to mask it
you can rewrite the program
and here you're using some random bit
strings to try to
randomize the sensitive bit before using
it in this leaky computation
now here you can see that m1 seems to be
logically dependent on this random bit
right first of all it's
synthetically dependent and second of
all it's if you if you look at
harder you would realize that it's also
logically dependent it's semantically
dependent on this random disk
so it seems that it has been masked
but still you don't know whether the
mask is perfect or not
so the real question here is after the
masking
do we know whether n1 is now
statistically independent from
the secret [ __ ] i want so that's the
verification
problem and you can imagine that
conceptually you could build a huge
truth table right this is going to be of
size exponential right
but and then start counting then the
number of ones in the first half the
second half
but this will be not practical
so that's really the verification
problem
now we're ready to talk about our method
for uh for
automatically synthesizing uh static
analyzer to software verification
problem
uh just one one minor point there seems
to be some noise coming from your end
perhaps an open window or something i
wonder if uh
yeah that that helps a lot thank you is
it better now
yeah much better thanks okay
thank you so our method uh starts with
some kind of a training data so here the
training data are
programs and type annotations
these type annotations indicate whether
the corresponding programs have
leaks or not and then we have two
components
one is the learner and the other is the
approver
the learner is responsible for
generating analysis rules from the
training data and then the approver
is responsible for proving them and only
the proof the rules will be added to the
learn analyzer
and in in in that sense we can guarantee
that the learned analyzer is going to be
provably sound
and all the rejected rules will produce
counter examples which will be added
back to the training data
and so we in the future we won't see the
same rules generated again
so now let's look into the the learner
the learner would have two interacting
components a one is for synthesizing the
analysis rules
and the other is for synthesizing the
features
for the root synthesis we're using
decision tree learning and for the
feature sentences
we're using syntax guided sentences so
i'm going to explain in
in the next few slides why we make such
choices
so now let's look at two concrete
examples so
from the training data we can extract
some abstract syntax trees
these are representing the intermediate
computation results of the program
and the type annotations start with the
input
so we can label the inputs here ukd
stands for unknown
means that we're not sure if this one is
uh
is is leaky or not so let's just assume
it's not secure it's leaky
and then this in rand means the imp it's
an input bit
and it's a random input bit
and once we have the lower level uh
labels we can start labeling
the uh the the remaining nodes
so here b2 will be labeled rud
means random uniform distribution means
that it has been perfectly masked it's
considered secure
and the reason is because one of its
operands
r2 is actually the input bit
and it's randomized and this is
exclusive or so whatever
the other operand is this is perfectly
masked
so similarly we can label the other
nodes
and this thoughts process can be
codified as the analysis
rule and this rule basically says well
look look at b2 if the left operand
is ukd the right operand is
in rand and the operation is exclusive
r then this is perfectly masked
and this may sounds trivial but i'm
using it here to just give you an idea
of what this
kind of analysis will look like
now we try to label the top level nodes
here
n1 is actually ukd although
both of its children are perfectly
masked they are actually masked by the
same random bit so
at the top level the masking is going to
be removed accidentally
but for the other node it remains rud
because
the two children are using two different
random bits for the masking
and the difference between these two
asts can be codified by
another analysis rule and this rule is a
little bit more complex because he's
using some recursive relations like
dom here but essentially it says
you know a ast tree has to be
uh looking more like the right hand side
in order to be labeled rub
clear dom means you know the left child
must be recursively dependent on some
random bit or l and the right hand side
child has to be recursively dependent on
some random bit
or r and rl and rr are different
so by now hopefully uh it's clear that
we need to learn
two things one is a set of features
and the other is the set of rules
the features are really the predicates
that are used in these
rules they can be the distribution types
the unary operators the binary operators
and also this kind of
recursive relations the rules are really
the sufficient conditions
for a certain node to to be of a certain
distribution type
if you're familiar with data log you'd
see these are essentially data logger
rules
uh if you're familiar with foreign
clauses these are the
you know first are logic horn clauses
so for learning the rules we're using
decision tree learning
and the reason is because if you look at
a decision tree like this
you would see that path in the tree
naturally correspond to some sufficient
conditions
for a certain program variable to have a
certain distribution type like rud
and and so each tree captures a set of
analysis rules in our case if we apply
this decision tree to some concrete
program
then we can label we can classify for
each program
its distribution type
so this is all very nice but there are
sometimes
the current set of features you have to
construct the decision tree
may not be expressive enough and that's
when you would observe
some path like this red path where
at the bottom there are these two nodes
before and
and one according to the ground truth
they should have different labels but
because we don't have enough
uh features for for constructing this
tray we're not able to separate them
so so this is when we will know
that we need more features
so that's why this feature synthesis is
going to be invoked
on demand whenever this tree has
ambiguity
and so this is basically syntax guided
synthesis
from a certain grammar we would be able
to construct the
uh new feature and and this new feature
has to be able to reduce the ambiguity
of this trade
in the in the context of decision tree
learning so this new feature when it's
added
it's supposed to be able to increase the
information again along this kind of a
rap path
so if we keep doing that um all these
ambiguities in the current decision tree
will be
eventually removed and we would have a
decision tree
that is fully consistent with all the
training examples
so the ground truth so that's when we
are
ready to move on to the proverb here
we need to ask this question are the
learned rules
sound not just for the training programs
but
also for the all the valid i mean all
the other on-scene programs
for which you might want to apply this
analyzer
and this as you can imagine is a
challenging uh problem because
you know the set of unknown programs is
is infinite
so unlike the training programs you
cannot enumerate them
and then try to validate the rule on
each of them
so instead you need to think about this
as a
query containment checking problem so
here
you can assume that this learn rule
alpha
is is a data log query and we also need
to build
a proof system uh which we call the
knowledge base
and it all also can be expressed as a
data log query
now you have to develop queries you want
to prove that
one query is contained in another so
in terms of the query language uh
containment
so that's one way to understand this
disapprover
another way to understand the prover is
to think of the alpha
as a physiologic formula and and kv has
another verso logic formula and both are
represented in the form of quaran
clauses now
the question is how do we prove that
alpha entails kb
now we took whichever way we take um the
prover needs to
be able to produce two possible outcomes
one is that the learned rule is proved
to be sound in which case it will be
added to the learner
to to the analyzer or if it fails to
prove it
it will just produce some abstract
counter examples that will be added
back to the training data set
so the knowledge base is a set of proof
rules
that are known to be correct so in this
work we have two set of
proof rules one is for propositional
logic the other is for the distribution
types
we know that for propositional logic
there are some and conclude proof rules
so
these rules are just taken from textbook
for the distribution types
uh these are rules collected from prior
publications
on formerly verifying masking counter
measures
and these are the rules that have been
proved to be sound so we're just taking
it and use it here
now we have two a set of queries the
alpha and the kb
we're ready to to decide the query
containment
um i want to make two key points here
first
uh data log query containment checking
is known to be undecidable in general
but but in practice there are decidable
fragments and
for for our context all the rules that
that we see in practice are in this
decidable fragment
but our synthesis framework actually
doesn't really need uh
the uh the procedure to be fully
decidable right
we only need it to be cyanide decidable
so here's what i mean
if you imagine that kb and alpha as
queries
so the queries would return some some
results right these are the set of
programs
uh for which the labels are consistent
with the queries
now we can imagine the entire universe
as all the possible
programs that you might want to apply
your analyzer
kb defines a subset these are the secure
regions
and as long as alpha the the subset is
defined by alpha
falls within this secure region then we
know that alpha is the sum
so in the actual implementation we're
proving alpha entails kb
using uh smg solver together with
pay induction so i'm not going to go
into the details but the high level
it's it's it's analogous to unbounded
model checking where you just keep
on unwinding on rolling the recursive uh
formulas inside the data log programs of
both alpha and kb
and then you try to justify that alpha
always entails a b
so it's like any induction proof we just
first assume that this entailment holds
for all the k
minus one steps and and based on that we
try to show that you should also hold
for the case
step
so now we're ready to look at the
evaluation results
in the evaluation we want to ask two
questions first is the synthesize the
analyzer fast enough
and accurate enough when it's compared
with the state-of-the-art
hand profit analyzers the second
question is
whether the synthesis is really
effective there is a learner there is
approver
is the learner learning the useful
analysis rules
is the approver able to prove them
the benchmarks we use are c programs
that are
implementing uh cryptographic algorithms
so we have the training set training set
has 531 small programs
these are the code snippets annotated
with the ground truth
we also have the test set these are the
37 larger programs
taken from prior publications where they
were used for
benchmarking
so overall we see that the the
synthesized analyzer
achieved almost the same empirical
accuracy as
as the existing analyzer there are
37 test programs out of 37
on 33 of them the the the results are
the same
so there is no uh difference in the
analysis results only four of them we
see
differences so out of these four uh
these are the three
where our learn analyzer doesn't perform
as well
uh it reported more ukd the unknown
types
and and on one of them our learn
analyzer
does a little bit better it reported
fewer
unknown cases but overall the empirical
accuracy are almost the same the real
difference is in the
execution time we will look at the
execution time we find that
um our learned analyzer is much faster
than the existing analyzers
for the most recent ones we are more
than
200 times faster for for the for the
older ones it would wear more than
900 times faster
and here are the results on the
synthesis procedure
so the synthesis procedure is
reasonably fast so it took 30 iterations
uh where each iteration is a
repeated invocation of the learner and
an approver for constructing different
type of
decision trace and each iteration took
like
one or two seconds here the x-axis are
the 30 iterations the y-axis are the
execution time in seconds
these are more statistics on the learner
and the approver
along the axis again these are the 30
iterations y-axis
showing the number of synthesized
features uh
the the rules learned the rules verified
and also the
number of abstract counter examples uh
added back to the training data set
so as you can see that as the number of
iteration increases
uh we're learning more and more features
and uh
the the learned rules are most of them
are approved
and it seems to be doing what we were
expecting it to do
so our conclusion is that through this
work
uh we found that data-driven synthesis
seems to be a good idea
at least for in practice for
synthesizing a
side channel analyzer it's fully
automated and it's provably sound and
we're not thinking about applying
similar ideas to other side channels
and as as i mentioned at the beginning
of this talk
there are many other such channels
they're all very exciting
a higher level you can see that uh a
side channel verification uh
tool is is only a part of the story
it's for either detecting
vulnerabilities or verifying that there
is no
vulnerability but there are also these
related questions
uh one is automated synthesis of counter
measures
and the other is if you are given an
existing implementation
you might want to quantifying uh you
want
one you want might want to quantify the
amount of information leakage for
example you
uh using uh notions like channel entropy
or
main entropy so overall this is a nice
uh application of automated uh
you know formal analysis or program
synthesis
so we've done some work uh in the past
uh along some of this
direction so if you're interested i i
listed some of these
related papers on this topic
so that that's all what i want to say
i wonder if there are questions thank
you thank you ciao
that's a very interesting results and i
would say a very innovative use of
synthesis
um are there any questions from the
audience
okay i had a couple of questions let me
start off with that um
so um i wonder in your use of scigirls
did you
you know do you have any thoughts on
where current sagas technology falls
short
for this particular applications like
what sort of
what sort of uh things you feel
would be useful to have insight solvers
to be able to push the boundaries for
this particular class of
synthesis problems for our application
uh we think it's uh it's working fine
because we're only using it to
synthesizing these uh uh features uh
these are the only the predicates
and and then when we try to use this uh
features to try to piece together the uh
the the analysis rules we're using uh
uh decision tree learning um and the
reason is because the decision tree
learning is
is more scalable and in theory you can
imagine well why don't you synthesize
the
whole rule you're using using scientists
you you can there's there's no reason
you cannot
but but if you if you think about it
along the same way
then why don't you just uh replace
decision tree learning everywhere with
the cycles right you can also do that
in practice but but probably in that
case you cannot
construct a decision tree that is bigger
than uh you know
four levels right we saw existing papers
where
some people actually do that you
operational research right so
mixed into linear programming where they
tried that
and uh beyond four levels
uh it might be very hard it would just
run for several
hours right right okay um and then i had
another question about one of your one
of the graphs in your results
so when you you showed you had these
four plots on one slide
and you showed uh the the number of
verified rules
right right here right bottom left so
this
uh fluctuates and i'm trying to
understand what the reason it fluctuates
is because
uh one of the new counter examples you
get
refutes number of rules and so you you
have fewer a few
verified rules so what is what is going
on there ah
so the the the these rules are uh
the they are all consistent with uh the
training
examples so correct but uh but
you don't know whether they they are
also valid for all possible
programs that you might encounter in the
future so
so the the the prover uh may or may not
be able to prove it
and there are two possibilities one is
that the room may actually
be invalid for for for some other
on-site programs
in that case you have to drop it in
other cases
it might be uh valid but the prover is
weaker you cannot prove it you have to
drop it
so but it's it's not like
all the learned rules are dropped that
would be really bad so so in this case
we're we're happy because you know
you know quite a few of them were proved
they were added right
what is the alternative of coming up
with this rules uh without
our tool you'd have to ask a domain
expert to sit down and try to
you know paper and pencil try to come up
with these rules right
so in that sense this we're happy with
the result here
i see got it okay are there any other
questions from the audience
so i have a question so do you have a
sense of how scigirls
can be or synthesis in general can be
used to
solve the problem of quantification of
the amount of information
leaked like what you were suggesting at
the end yes
let me go to here
so this slide really shows you know the
quantification uh
one way of looking at it is you know you
build a truth table you start counting
the number of ones here in the first
half and the second half so
this fundamentally is is a model
counting problem
uh so there are people who are uh
working on model counting sat solvers uh
smt solvers you know with various kind
of constraints
uh if you do that then then you could uh
you could
quantify right you give you get a piece
of java code or c
code you say certain inputs are uh
random and then you try to quantify if
if if you have leakage so so that has
there has been
quite quite a few exciting works uh
recently
along that fly and both both on the
server side and
on buying the server for actually
quantifying
timing side channel leaks and other type
of side channel links
i see i mean i just thought like model
counting is hard on its own so
it is it is so the the difference
between the analyzer we have is
we actually avoided model counting we
want to have a
sound but fast analyzer
so when we cannot resolve a certain uh
variable we would see unknown right in
that case you might want to apply model
counting
to further refine the decision so we
actually have a cap paper two three
years ago
that is combining the uh this type
inference together with smaller copy
you run a fast type uh inference and
then
put on resolve the nodes uh you run the
model party
all right uh thank you ciao once again
for a very interesting talk
um yeah thank you
and so let's move back to